فساد متجددر في مفاصل الدوله في اوكرانيا
ورثته عن حقبه الاتحاد السوفيتي عماقته
الحرب بما تحمله من فوضى تزيد فرص
الاستغلال تقاطع بين الحرب والفساد فقام
الازمه الاوكرانيه خاصه في المؤسسه
العسكريه
اقالات واستقالات طالت عددا من المسؤولين
الاوكران على خلفيه فضائح فساد
ايضا عقود مبالغ فيها شراء منتجات غذائيه
للعسكريين في مكاتب وزاره الدفاع ليست
حاله فرديه مخاوف من شبهات تصل الى نطاق
واسع خاصه في المؤسسه العسكريه لتطرح
احتماليه التحول اوكرانيا الى السوق
لتهريب الاسلحه تلك الاسلحه التي يقدمها
الغرب في اطار المساعدات العسكريه
حمله نجمت عن وعود اطلقها الرئيس لنسكي
منذ ثلاث سنوات يبدو انها تؤتي ثمارها
الان
واتعاهد باتخاذ قرارات رئيسيه بشان القضاء
عليه هذا الاسبوع
خاطئه وان الرقابه في الوزاره تتم على
العقود المبرمه
جهود انكب عليها جنسكي للرد على مخاوف
الغرب من سوء استخدام الاسلحه التي ترسل
لاوكرانيا الاستمرار مواجهه روسيا
الفساد هو عامل الثقه الذي سيجذب الحلفاء
الغربيين للاستمرار بتقديم المساعدات
العسكريه واعاده اعمار اوكرانيا التي تلقى
الضربه قاسيه في بنيتها التحتيه خلال اقل
من عام بل هو اكبر من ذلك على المدى
الطويل عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي مظله امان
تطالب بها اوكرانيا لحمايتها من زحف
البيدق الروس الى عمر العربيه